for me the secret of a great gazpacho
is over ripe tomatoes
peppers cucumber a little bit of heat
with a garlic
we've got to leave it to marinade
first peppers cut around the flat edges
to minimize
waste then chop
the nice thing about
making the gazpacho there's no set
recipe
because you can put it together
purely all tomatoes
half peppers half tomatoes
i like the flavor of the cucumber in
there as well that gives it that
freshness
the secret
of a great dispatcher is the longer you
leave it marinating
the better the flavor
so if you can get this done the night
before and left in the
fridge the results are stunning
the green and red peppers have subtly
complementary flavors and go well with
ripe tomatoes
start off by removing the bitter core
get a little knife
and just
put it in where the core is and twist it
around and you get this little
core out i remember my first experience
eating a gazpacho in spain
mind blowing i've never forgotten that
quarter your tomatoes keeping the juicy
seeds that add so much depth of taste
nice then from there
cucumber
just peel that the seeds i'm gonna leave
in
that gives it the flavor
and the texture cucumber and gazpacho
does exactly what it does in a pims it
sort of freshens it up
and makes it mouth-watering slice that
in half
again
into quarters and chop
now to give gazpacho its unique texture
and thicken the soup bread and the
crispy the crust the better then garlic
thinly sliced
next spring onions nice and roughly
chopped
and basil stalks and all we can use
stalks and
basil stalks parsley stalks tarragon
stalks they have the most amazing flavor
basil in
and now we'll start marinating
salt black pepper and a good coating of
olive oil this gives it a glossy creamy
flavor
and the cherry vinegar that's the
perfect vinegar
for the gazpacho it's a strong acidic
complement
to the flavors
and just mix it up and the smell already
is incredible
it doesn't look
like a gazpacho but by the time this
marinades
and all those flavors start getting to
know one another
all of a sudden you've got this huge
explosion
of contrast
now
push that down in the restaurants
we press the marinade down overnight a
couple of big pans on top and we crush
all the ingredients and then blitz it
the next day
the flavor is extraordinary leave all
those fresh ingredients packed with
goodness to marinade from half an hour
to even overnight and then when you
blend it
it just comes together
like this sumptuous rich
delicious chilled soup
to go with my super tasty soup i've got
an ultra healthy and exciting dessert
carpaccio of pineapple which is a chefy
way of saying super thinly sliced
it's done with a twist
we're gonna have a delicious
flavoured
salt
has to be flavored with vanilla simply
scrape out the vanilla seeds and add to
sea salt along with the pot to store
now that basically keeps river there's
no sale by date because it's salt and
vanilla so
so fragrant so delicious you don't need
much of this fragrant salt to intensify
the sweetness of the pineapple
pineapple
[Music]
sliced peeled pineapple into wafer thin
pieces it's almost like nice little
discs
slightly transparent
[Music]
once you've sliced the pineapple take
the flavor to another level
a light sprinkle of vanilla salt and
arrange the pineapple in a flower shape
[Music]
it's a beautiful way of finishing
a meal
the fragrance
other than
the crunch
with the salt
and the vanilla salt just marinades
the pineapple beautifully then scatter
nutrient rich pomegranate seeds over the
top to finish finely shredded fresh mint
just
slice them
really thin and then
that'll give that nice cool
minty flavor
pineapple
my carpaccio is ready and my gazpacho
has been marinating in the fridge
time to blend the soup
in
onto your blender
and start off
nice and slowly
blend until super fine and gloriously
silky and serve refreshingly cold
get your bowl
and pour it in
now to finish it get some fresh basil
roll it nice and tight
and shred it
and then drop it into your bowl
fresh
chopped basil
and then finally
just a touch of extra virgin olive oil
just to give that really nice additional
freshness
and look at that healthy and delicious
gazpacho soup to me is a taste of
mediterranean sunshine in a bowl
followed by the wafer thin capacity of
pineapple with jewels of pomegranate
goodness for dessert
practically all of your five a day in
one incredible healthy lunch
my next simple salad that's perfect for
a party is green bean salad with mustard
dressing
[Music]
for the dressing wrap a whole bulb of
garlic in foil
and roast it in a hot oven next add top
and tail green beans to salted boiling
water
and cook for just a couple of minutes
this is called blanching and keeps the
beans deliciously crunchy
[Music]
strain the beans
and refresh in cold water this stops the
cooking process so they stay crisp and
green
[Music]
next remove your garlic from the oven
[Music]
cut off the head
and squeeze out all the glorious garlic
which has gone creamy mellow and divine
in the oven
[Music]
then simply add sharp white wine vinegar
a dollop of dijon mustard and sweet
runny honey
season
and pour in a good glug of olive oil
then whisk
[Music]
add the crunchy blanched green beans and
topped with toasted almonds for a lovely
nutty note and crunchy texture
mix well
and serve
[Music]
heavily mustard vinaigrette with a hit
of mellow roast garlic stunning green
beans dressed to perfection
[Music]
my next salad that's great for any big
bash is roasted red pepper lentil and
herb salad
[Music]
add pre-lentils to vegetable stock
along with a bay leaf and boil for 15
minutes
pre lentils are perfect for sellers they
have a great meaty flavor and a
delicious bite for texture
next chop sweet red peppers
and place on a baking tray
along with diced courgette
drizzle over olive oil
season
and roast in a hot oven
to assemble the salad
place the drain lentils in a large bowl
[Music]
then add olive oil
[Music]
and chop some blush tomatoes
take the roasted red peppers and
courgettes from the oven and add
along with chopped avocado as its
delicious creamy flesh gives the salad a
lovely contrast
[Music]
season
then for a big herby hit chop a handful
of chives and basil
and add
squeeze over lemon juice
and mix
earthy aromatic and packed full of
goodness absolutely stunning so with
roasted meats and fish or perfect eaten
just by itself
you